the author of the pre-sentence report is
of the same view and assesses your risk
as very high
in my judgment acknowledging that a life
sentence is a last resort the section 18
offense is in itself serious enough to
justify a life sentence and there is no
reliable estimate of the length of time
you will remain a danger
in any event of course you will be
serving the life sentence which I will
impose for the murder of Jermaine
the minimum term which I attach to the
life sentence for the murder must
include a term to reflect the section 18
offense as the sentence which I impose
for that offense will run concurrently
with the sentence on the murder
having started at 17 years for the
appropriate minimum term I have
concluded that the aggravating factors
for the murder outweigh the mitigation
and that a minimum term of 19 years
would have been appropriate in your case
before considering the section 18
offense
from that minimum term should be
deducted three years just under 1 6 to
reflect your plea of guilty which gives
16 years
having determined that the notional
determinant sentence for the section 18
would have been six years I Am pro I
propose to increase the minimum term for
the murder to one of 19 years to reflect
totality
would you stand up please
the sentences I pass upon you are as
follows for the murder detention at his
Majesty's pleasure
the minimum term before you will be
considered for released by the parole
board will be one of 19 years
for the possession of the murder weapon
there will be a sentence of eight months
detention to run concurrently
causing previous bodily harm with intent
there will be a discretionary life
sentence of detention at his Majesty's
pleasure with a minimum term of four
years that sentence will run
concurrently to the sentence for the
murder
you have spent 497 days in detention on
remand which will count towards your
sentence so the minimum term is 19 years
less 497 days
if the information which I have been
provided with as to the days in
detention on remand proves to be
inaccurate then the prosecution or
defense must notify the court so that
the case can be re-listed to correct the
calculation as soon as possible and in
any event within 56 days of today
you will not be released when you have
served that minimum term indeed you will
only ever be released if the parole
board consider that you no longer pose a
risk of harm to the public
that's a sentence